Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Cevick. Ich bin heute Ihre zuständige Ärztin auf dieser Station und möchte mit Ihnen das Anamnesegespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Aber natürlich. Bitte schön.
Okay. Bevor Sie mir Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden nennen, bräuchte ich einige persönliche Daten.
Sie können jederzeit fragen, wann etwas Ihnen unklar ist.
Also, wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Hans Kanton.
Könnten Sie mir Ihren Nachnamen langsam bestabieren?
Kanton, wie in der Schweiz Kanton, also K-A-N-T-O-N.
Okay, Herr Kanton. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 48 Jahre alt.
Wie waren Sie genau geboren?
Am 23. August, 1900, was habe ich gesagt, 48?
76? Nein, 78.
78, ja.
76?
Ja, 76.
Pardon.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Kanton?
1,95 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zurzeit?
Ja, ein Moment, ein bisschen viel, 123 kg.
132?
23.
23, okay.
Vielen Dank für die Angaben, Herr Kanton.
Welche Beschwerden haben Sie? Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Herr Doktor, ich weiß nicht, wo ich anfangen soll.
Ich habe viele Beschwerden in den letzten 2-3 Tagen.
Ich habe seit ungefähr einem halben Jahr merke ich,
dass meine Luft bei Belastung immer weg bleibt, immer knapper wird.
Aber ich habe das nicht ernst genommen.
Jetzt wird das schlimmer.
Seit 3 Tagen habe ich so einen enge Gefühl und so einen Druck auf den Brust.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt Angst bekommen und bin hergekommen.
Sie haben seit einem halben Jahr Luftnot immer schlimmer geworden.
Seit 2-3 Tagen auch Luftnot und enge Gefühl.
Ja, genau.
Wo fühlen Sie diese enge Gefühl hinter dem Brustbein?
Hier vorne, genau.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass die Strahl ein bisschen in den Hals
und so ein bisschen in die linke Schulter manchmal.
Und der linke auch manchmal komisch.
Genau.
Okay.
Herr Kanton, muss ich jetzt diese Gespräche kurz unterbrechen?
Ich muss Ihre Kreislaufwerte erst mal messen.
Ihre Vitalparameter werden von meinen Kollegen gemessen
und ich schreibe Ihnen ein EKG.
Wenn alles in Ordnung ist, können wir unser Gespräch fortfahren.
Ist das was Schlimmes?
Ja, ich kann jetzt nicht genau sagen, aber es könnte sein.
Aus Sicherheit wollte ich diese Untersuchungen erst mal durchführen.
Und auch Sauerstoffsetigung werde ich messen
und wir kommen Sie über die Nase, damit wir unsere Kreislaufwerte fortführen können.
Okay.
Sie haben enge Gefühl und auch haben Sie Schmerzen an der Brust?
Nicht immer, das kommt und geht.
Nur manchmal.
Wann kommen die Schmerzen?
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt, zum Beispiel bei Bewegung und Belastung?
Also wie ich schon sagte, wenn ich zu stark belaste, dann kommt es verstärkt.
Da kommt die Luftnot und danach dieses enge Gefühl.
Sie belassen zu stark und bekommen Sie diese Schmerzen, enge Gefühl und auch Luftnot?
Ja.
Okay.
Zum Beispiel, wie viele Treppen können Sie hochlaufen, ohne Luftnot zu bekommen?
Also früher bin ich drei, vier Stockwerke ohne Pause gelaufen.
Okay, dass ich jetzt nach einem Stockwerk ein bisschen stehen muss,
ein bisschen Luft atmen muss und dann weitermachen kann.
Seit zwei, drei Tagen meinen Sie.
Nur ein Stockwerk können Sie schaffen und dann Pause machen.
Genau.
Okay.
Hatten Sie ganz früher nicht beschwerden oder nur halben Jahr?
Das ist das erste Mal eigentlich.
Diese erste Mal.
Okay.
Und in laufender Zeit diese Beschwerden immer Schildimmer geworden?
Ja.
Auch am Anfang sind diese Schmerzen oder diese ganze Beschwerden plötzlich angefangen
oder langsam können Sie sagen?
Also seit zwei Tagen ging es eigentlich akut, muss ich sagen.
Okay.
Und wie viel Tag sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkalafon,
null bis zehn, wobei null keine Schmerzen sind,
sehr heftige Schmerzen entspricht?
Also wenn es mal mit diesem Engige für meinen Sie,
und die Schmerzen, so fünf, sechs, würde ich sagen, wenn es mal kommt.
Wenn es mal kommt, fünf, sechs.
Und wie lange dauert diese Engige-Gefühl?
Eine halbe Stunde bleibt das schon.
Halbe Stunde, okay.
Immer halbe Stunde ungefähr.
Wenn Sie kommen, den Sie dauerhaft.
Wie dauerhaft?
Das bleibt schon.
Und wie viel Meter können Sie laufen, ohne Schmerzen
oder ohne Engige-Gefühl, ohne Luftnot zu haben?
Ja, dazu.
Beim Laufen merke ich das nicht so.
Es ist mehr, wenn ich eine körperliche Anstrengung habe.
Okay.
Normaler laufen nicht.
Normaler laufen keine.
Okay.
Wie können Sie diese Engige-Gefühl und Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie eher dumpf, brennend, zähend, stechend?
Nee, das ist eher so, da habe ich das Gefühl,
als ein großer Elefant mehr auf der Brust sitzt.
Engige-Gefühl, ja, so ein Stechen ist das eigentlich.
Okay.
Haben Sie dagegen etwas eingenommen?
Bist ja eigentlich noch nicht, nein.
Haben Sie deswegen beim anderen Arzt gesucht?
War ich noch nicht.
Ich wollte eigentlich nächste Woche zum Hausarzt,
aber nach den Beschmerzen jetzt doch so heftig geworden sind,
bin ich gleich zu Ihnen hierhergekommen.
Okay.
Haben Sie ein Auslöser- oder Versteckfaktor,
außer Belastung bemerkt?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Belastung, okay.
Was versteckt,
hat sich die Schmerzen erkannt und haben Sie etwas bemerkt?
Nein, weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Können Sie flach liegen in der letzten Zeit
oder seit diesen halben Jahren?
Flach liegen ist noch kein Problem, nein.
Okay, können Sie.
Haben Sie Beinschwellung?
Nein, bisher nicht, nein.
Beinschwellungen im Bein habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Nein, nicht, okay.
War Ihnen Schwindel?
Nein, Schwindelig.
Schwindelig.
Okay, nein.
Verspüren Sie Herzlagen, Herzstolpern oder Herzklopfen?
Also nicht, aber manchmal habe ich so einen kräftigen Herzschlag,
das stimmt.
Wenn die Schmerzen mal oder dieses Engelgeffen kommt,
dann habe ich das Gefühl, das klopft ganz kräftig
und das ist immer so, als ob es stolpert, diese Herzfrequenz.
Verspüren Sie diese Herzstolpern seit zwei bis drei Tagen oder?
Ja, da ist es verstärkt.
Das habe ich immer wieder gehabt, aber ich habe es nicht erkannt.
Okay, jetzt ist es stark.
Ja, ja.
Schwitzen Sie mehr Herkantun oder kalte Schweiz, haben Sie bemerkt?
Das habe ich nicht, nein.
Fühlen Sie sich fieberig?
Nein.
Nachtschweiß, haben Sie Nachtschweiß?
Nein, habe ich auch.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Blasehaut oder leuliche Veränderungen
an der Haut bemerkt?
Bin ich aufgefallen, nein.
Nein, okay.
Und wie ist die Appetit?
Also bisher ganz gut, ich bin mit 120 kg.
Appetit, gut.
Und in der letzten Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, alles unbefällt.
Okay.
Abnehmen, aber ich schaffe es nicht so.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Nein.
Ab die Toilette in der Nacht?
Nein, nein.
Häufig?
Nein, alles gut.
Stuhl auch in Ordnung?
Ja.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen übel oder war Ihnen übelt herkantun?
Nein, wenn du es enger gefühl kommst, dann hat man das Gefühl, es ist eine leichte Übelkeit dabei.
Okay.
Nein, aber müssten Sie schon erbrechen?
Nein.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Husten?
Nein.
Okay.
Schlafen Sie gut, normalerweise?
Ja, aber ich habe kein Problem.
Okay.
Jetzt komme ich zu Ihren Vorerkrankungen herkantun.
Leiden Sie andauerhaften Erkrankungen?
Nein.
Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheiten, Beispiel oder erhöhte Blutfettwerte könnte sein?
Bisher nichts bekannt, ja.
Okay, das freut mich.
Und wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Nein, auch nicht.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein?
Ja, aber wenn ich mal Schmerzen habe, dann nehme ich mal einen E-Bö-Profen, aber
ansonsten habe ich keine Medikamente.
Okay.
Und sind Ihnen irgendwelche Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt herkantun?
Nein, nicht eigentlich.
Ich habe keine Erkrankungen.
Okay.
Und sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Auch wegen Corona?
Mein Haushalt habe ich mal vor vielen angesprochen.
Ich glaube es fehlen ein paar Impfungen.
Die Tetanus müsste ich glaube ich erneuern.
Corona-Impfungen habe ich die letzten zwei nicht gemacht.
Ich hatte vor hat ich zwei schon.
Ja, achten Sie darauf, ja, Aufricht im Funken sind wichtig.
Ja, und am Haus als auch immer so.
Ich mag.
Okay, das verstehe ich.
Und waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Nein.
Okay, jetzt komme ich zu Ihren Lebensgewohnheiten, Herr Kanton, Rauchen Sie?
Ja, leider habe ich dieses Laste.
Ja, wie viel Rauchen Sie täglich und seit wann?
Kein Sie nicht nach.
Also, das kann schon sein, so bis zwei Packungen am Tag.
Und?
Seit wann Rauchen Sie so?
Über 30 Jahre schon.
35.
Ja, ungefähr.
Das ist aber zu viel.
Haben Sie einmal versucht, damit auch zu hören?
Ja, ich habe schon mehrfach, aber ich schaffte es irgendwie nicht.
Okay, wenn Sie wollen, können wir Sie dabei unterstützen.
Nach unserem Gespräch können wir darüber sprechen.
Wenn Sie wollen.
Ich würde sagen, wir machen erst mal hier.
Ja, natürlich.
Und das Rauchen ist, glaube ich, eine langfristige Geschichte.
Ja, okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol, Herr Kanton?
Ja, schon ab und zu.
Was meinen Sie ab und zu?
Jeden Tag oder nur ab und zu?
Da ist ein Bier am Abend, das kann auch mal zwei Fleisch werden.
Ich glaube, das ist normal.
Sie sind hier auch Alkohol.
Aber manchmal zu einem Feier und auch mal ein Wein dazu.
Ja, okay, feierlich dazu Wein, aber jeden Tag zwei Fleisch, Bier täglich.
Ungefähr, ja.
Ungefähr.
Seit wann?
Oh, auch schon.
22 Jahre, glaube ich.
Okay, das ist auch so viel.
Und jetzt jetzt die Frage, nehmen Sie bitte nicht persönlich,
das ist eine Routine-Mess-Gefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie einen Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ja, was meinen Sie jetzt genau mit Drogen?
Oder Kokain oder Heroin habe ich nicht.
Aber kiffer manchmal schon.
Also das heißt, ich nehme Cannabis und so weiter.
Ja, das mache ich ab und zu.
Ja, Cannabis ab und zu.
Ja.
Nehmen Sie.
Okay.
Okay, verstehe mich.
Und jetzt möchte ich über über Ihre Familie sprechen.
Haben Ihre Eltern irgendwelche Krankheiten?
Okay, weiß ich jetzt nicht so genau.
Ich habe auch wenig Kontakt zu meinen Eltern, aber so weit ich weiß,
hat mein Vater, glaube ich, einen Blutdruck, einen hohen Blutdruck.
Ich meine, die sind beide ganz viel.
Die machen Wanderungen, die reisen rum und meine Mutter nimmt ja auch so vieles ein,
mit Vitaminen und was auch immer.
Ich glaube, die hat keine Grundschnellkrankungen bis zu viel.
Okay, leben Sie noch?
Ja, ja, ja.
Okay, das freut mich.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein.
Okay, Herr Kanton, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet und habe zwei Kinder hier.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, Glückwunsch.
Ja, Gott sei Dank.
Und was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Freikmanager.
Ja, gut.
Und haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Oh, nur.
Okay, und die letzte Frage.
Wenn Sie diese enge Gefühl oder Luftnot
erst mal bekommen haben, in der letzten Zeit, meine ich,
Was haben Sie gemacht?
Vielleicht viel Stress oder bei Belastung?
Ich bin immer auf dem Stress, denn das haben wir jeden Tag.
Immer, nicht besonders.
Okay.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht.
Okay, ich bin fertig mit meinen Fragen.
Herr Kanton, möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, aber es ist aus dem EKG geworden.
Sie haben doch vorhin noch ein bisschen Blut abgenommen.
Haben wir da schon Ergebnis im EKG?
Können Sie etwas sehen?
Jetzt gibt es keine Auffälligkeiten,
aber sollen wir noch mal diese EKG wiederholen.
Und natürlich, ich werde sie körperlich untersuchen
und ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Okay.
Aber nach Ihren Angaben, das könnte vom Herz verursachen.
Ah, okay.
Nach alle Ergebnissen können wir noch mal darüber sprechen.
Okay, alles klar.
Mhm.
Das war meine Frage.
Ich glaube, da kommt nichts Schlimmes raus.
Vielen Dank.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Ich habe Fragen für Sie, Herr Kanton.
Ja, bitte.
Also, haben Sie auch Angst,
Angstegefühle mit der Schmessen dabei?
Angstgefühle.
Angstgefühle?
Ja.
Also es ist sehr beengend auf der Brüche.
Macht natürlich schon manchmal Angst, aber es ist mehr
Bezirkegefühle, bestimmt.
Müssen Sie nachts aufwachen vor der Schmessen?
Nein, das habe ich ja noch nicht erfahren.
Nein.
Okay, danke.
Schmessenintensität hat gefragt, hat gefragt, oder?
Herzkap?
Ja.
5 oder 6 hat gesagt.
Dauer ist gefragt.
Hat sie schon, ja.
Okay.
Wenn Sie Brüche merken bekommen,
ist es noch etwas zur selben Zeit?
Bitte?
Wir haben gesagt nur Übelkeit.
Ja.
Wenn Sie Brüche merken haben,
ist es noch etwas zur selben Zeit?
Nein, nein.
Nein.
Das ist eine Frage.
Was ist das für Sie?
Ich habe gesagt,
ist es noch etwas zur selben Zeit?
Nein, nein.
Nur Übelkeit?
Ja.
Okay.
Keine Fragen?
Natürlich hat gefragt.
Nein.
Mhm.
Dann machen wir als Arztgespräch?
Ja, bitte schön.
Brauchen Sie noch ein bisschen Zeit, Frau Doktor?
Ja, ich versuche.
Schönen Abend, liebe Oberarzt.
Ich habe heute mit einem neuen Patienten das an der Amnesiegespräch geführt.
Ah, so eine Amtsvorgollegin,
unsere neue Kollegin.
Ja, genau.
Haben gut eingearbeitet.
Wie fühlen Sie sich?
Ja, ganz gut.
Danke.
Okay, das freut mich.
Dann erzählen Sie mal,
welchen Patienten haben Sie aufgenommen?
Es handelt sich um Hans Kanton.
Herr Kanton sei 48 Jahre alt.
Am 3.
und 26.
1936 geboren.
1,95 m groß
und 123 kg schwer.
Herr Kanton stellte sich heute wegen
seit 2-3 Tagen bestehender,
akut aufgetretener,
progrediente
Bündnis
und auch seit 2-3 Tagen bestehender,
akut aufgetretener,
Belastung abhängiger, progrediente.
Okay.
Die nächsten Monate, das ist mir.
Nichts bei 3 Tagen.
Auch gleich.
Ich glaube, aber natürlich halben Jahr bestehender.
Ich sage danach, dass.
Ja, und akut aufgetretener,
belastet,
aber auch seit 2-3 Tagen bestehender,
ja, und akut aufgetretener,
Belastung abhängiger, progrediente.
Und retrosternal,
torokalgi,
mit Ausstrahlung in den Halsbereich
und in den linken Arm
bei uns vor.
Er ordnet die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala
von bei 5 bis 6 von 10 ein.
Und
außer dann berichtet der Patient,
dass er ähnliche Beschwerden auch seit
halbem Jahr
gehabt habe.
Und diese
der Schmerz
und engen Gefühl
dauere
halbe Stunde
und
die Schmerzen
der Patient
könne
früher 3-4
Stockwerke
Treppe
hochlaufen.
Aber in der letzten Zeit
könne er
nur ein Stockwerk hochlaufen
und dann
müsste er Pause machen.
Und
außer dann
leide er Kanton
als Begleitzentrum
unter Herzstolpern
und
engen Gefühl
die Fragen
Erpalkitationen sagen Sie, ja?
Ah, Palpitation, okay.
Und die Fragen nach
Orthopne, Neutri,
Beinödem, Vertigo
und
wurden verneint.
Der Patient habe
keine Medikamente
bisher eingenommen
und auch
habe er
keinen Arzt besucht.
Die Vegetativanamnese
zeigt
leichte Nausea.
Ansonst
die anderen Informationen sind
die unauffällig
vor Erkrankungen
und
für Operationen
wurden verneint.
Die Medikamenteanamnese
gab die Einnahme
von Ibuprofen bei Bedarf
und
beim Patienten
sei keine Allergie bekannt
und der im Status
sei nicht vollständig.
Gegen Corona
die letzten 2 Impfungen
haben der Patient nicht
machen lassen
und auch die Tönus
im Funk ist
nicht vollständig.
Die Reiseanamnese sei unauffällig.
Herr Kanton
ist Raucher
mit 2 Packungen
täglich seit
35 Jahren.
Das beträgt
Paketjahre.
Er trinkt
Alkohol, täglich
Zwerflaasche, Biya
seit 20 Jahren
und
manchmal
Wein auch
und
er rauche Cannabis
ab und zu.
In der Familienanamnese
leidet der Vater
an Artere Hepatoni
die Mutter
sei gesund.
Herr Kanton
sei Einzelkind
verheiratet habe 2
Gezunde Kinder
und sei Projektmanager
als von Beruf
und habe viel Stress
auf der Arbeit.
Die
Anamnestischen Angaben
deuten auf
den Akutes Coronar-Sendrum
und
als Differenzial Diagnose
kommen
Pneumotorax
und Pumpernaremboli
und
Anginapektoris
in Betracht.
ist auch eine Beschreibung der Symptome.
Ist es jetzt
keine Erkrankung?
Ja, okay.
Ein BWS-Syndrom
ist ein Brustverdiener
Schmerzen
von der Wirbelsäule
die Nachtbaune aufstrahlt.
Okay, aber
es dachte ich mal, nun gerne Probleme
erst mal als Differenzial Diagnose
könnte sein
oder Pneumotorax dachte ich.
Was
da noch sein?
Noch Differenzial Diagnostisch.
Ein enger Gefühl auf der Brust
das fällt hinein
vielleicht noch einen Blutdruck
Blutdruckdruck
eine rezipivierende
hypertensive Entgleisung
vielleicht mal der Grund sein
Magen, Gastventrationalbeschwerden
Ja,
ja, Ulcus ventricle
oder
die Sektion
Woran denkt man noch?
Irgendeine Orten
Orten, die Sektion
oder Orten, Ektasien
Also Probleme
mit der Orte
können auch mal solche Beschwerden machen
Ja, wenn du so viel rauchst
Woran denken sie noch?
COPD
COPD, das kann
von der Lunge her kommen
dass einfach Schluckdruck bekommt
Ja, also
müssen wir auch mal gucken
aber ich glaube
das aber wahrscheinlichsten
ist, wir müssen schauen
ob wir nicht ein Akkordes Corona
Alsyndrom mit bedacht auf KHK
so viel
Familienanämie
so viel rauchen
ja, die große
Terrienübergewicht
rauchen insbesondere
das kann schon sein, dass ein jünger Mensch
auch mal eine KHK natürlich hat
Sehr gut, okay
Sie machen ein EKG
und
gedenken natürlich auch an einen Vorhof
flimmern, das kann ja manchmal auch solche Beschwerden machen
dass man schlechter Luft bekommt
und das Herz
ist sehr gut